bonjour bonjour frédéric bhérer bonjour
monsieur mettre ko devant jour aux
auditeurs de martinique première voilà
donc vous êtes secrétaire fédéral du
parti socialiste en martinique
ça y'est frédéric bhérer les candidats
pour la primaire d'une partie de la
gauche sont connus ils sont sept
on va aller rappeler rapidement benoît
hamon arnaud montebourg vincent peillon
manuel valls une femme sylvia pinel du
parti radical de gauche jean luc
bennahmias qui représente le fond
démocrate et françois de rugy pour le
parti écologiste alors cette primaire
cette consultation va se tenir chez nous
les 21 et 28 janvier 1 c'est à dire en
français le 22 et 29 et on va voter
comme pour la primaire de la droite les
samedis 16 comme pour les élections
nationales
on voit que le samedi chine alors qui
organisera le scrutin de la primaire de
la belle alliance populaire parce que
c'est le nom exact et précis qui va
organiser ce scrutin chez nous est ce
que c'est vous seul la fsm la fédération
socialiste de la martinique ou est ce
qu'il y aura d'autres partis qui vont
ils prendre une part la précision quand
vous faites là est intéressante mais
l'alliance populaire c'est parce que ce
n'est pas une primaire avec seulement
les socialistes on retrouve les
syndicats laisse enfin il s'était ouvert
aux syndicats les ce monde associatif et
donc la belle alliance populaire
alors ici qui organise les primaires
bien entendu c'est la fédération
socialiste de martinique
mais nous ne sommes pas seuls nous
sommes en cela accompagné par le cam en
les progressistes le pp 1 et dès la
primaire les dead elle évoque la guinée
mais bien sa vocation
alors ils ne viennent pas organisé à la
place ils travaillent avec nous de
concert avec nous ce ça nous sommes tous
bien d'accord j'ai rencontré d'ailleurs
le président du ppm et le secrétaire
général moi même accompagné de quelques
camarades
nous avons discuté de cette affaire à
lorient loges et nous avons bien compris
que l'intérêt l'intérêt général de la
martinique
il faut commencer par faire voter appelé
à voter massivement pour les primaires
parce que le candidat qui sortira de ces
primaires il n'aura pas la même
légitimité s'il est choisi par mille
personnes que s'il est choisi pour 4000
ce sera toujours un candidat est notre
candidat mais nous voulons que notre
candidat soit massivement choisi
comment comment ça va s'articuler alors
vous nous dites bon le ppm va organiser
va tenir cette primaire avec vous mais
comment comment tout cela va s'articuler
avec le parti progressiste martiniquais
dont deux parlementaires d'ailleurs déjà
serge letchimy et serge larcher ont fait
un choix celui de soutenir la
candidature de manuel valls
avant même le résultat final vous savez
un nom à la fsm nous ne sécurisons par
le fait que si je puis m'exprimer ainsi
nous distinguons plutôt le fait que nous
saindon les choses nous organisons des
primaires organiser des primaires ne
veut pas de choisir un candidat
nous laissons les électeurs choisir le
candidat
cependant nous organisons le primaire
mais ce que des membres de la fsm
pourrait d'ores et déjà dès maintenant
s'exprimer à serait ce qu'à titre
personnel un boulet bien sûr mais ça a
même été fait déjà c'est dans les gènes
de notre parti d'ailleurs voilà pas vous
en tant que premier secrétaire vous avez
pas dire pour qui vous allez voter même
si on a une petite idée m'enfin
vous lisez dans mes pensées se voit que
ça nous a usés changé même si dans ces
échanges ne vous dit jamais que vous
êtes suffisamment observateurs
comprendre mais en tant que premier
secrétaire fédéral je m'oblige à ce
devoir de neutralité
donc je ne dirai pas quel candidat
alors qu'est ce que le pm va va
organiser quoi finalement vous dit non
ils seront avec vous à côté et cetera
mais bon ils vont mettre les mains dans
le cambouis pour mais bien sûr nous
avons déjà organisé une première séance
de travail est très intéressante
nous nous sommes dit un certain nombre
de choses nous avons évoqué un certain
nombre de chats et nous allons nous
rencontrer avant la fin de la semaine
pour travailler alors comment ça va se
passer comme vous dites
l'une des premières choses ils ont
beaucoup de monde autour d'eux ils ont
certaines municipalités de trouver des
choix pour installer des bureaux de vote
fixes et donc voilà tout ça sert les
jeunes est la logique veut qu'on va dire
jouer la logistique ensuite amené leurs
camarades leurs partisans à voter aux
primaires a participé à ce vote de que
ça c'est déjà conséquents comme
participation et puis dans dans diront
la propagande pour faire voter
d'ailleurs ce sera l'un des objets de
notre prochaine rencontre avant la fin
de la semaine pour se mettre d'accord
sur
les thèmes abordés pour faire voter sur
les slogans pour pour la primaire de la
droite
beaucoup de candidats de ces primaires
sont venus ici
est-ce que là d'ici un mois vous pensez
qu'il y à quelques candidats de la
primaire de gauche de la gauche je
pensais bien doit quand même
il va de soi bon maintenant je ne
détiens pas le calendrier je ne
programme pas le déplacement
je ne suis pas content le premier
secrétaire national jean christophe
comme à lille qui était aussi il ya
quelques jours sa maman j'ai été en
grande partie l'instigateur de cette
visite il le demande là aussi de venir
parce qu'il a compris que c'est un pote
s'il en était besoin parce qu'un
candidat qui se respecte quand meme
normalement ils se déplacent mais c'est
vrai que le teint coup tout le monde
n'aura peut-être pas les moyens non plus
de cessa de se déplacer dont
quelques-uns viendront dites moi
frédéric bhérer bon alors à l'orée de sa
campagne présidentielle et législatives
on va terminer là dessus rapidement mais
bon est-ce que le bilan du quinquennat
hollande avec une partie de ceux de ce
quinquennat avec manuel valls comme
premier ministre
ce que ce sera pas un boulet non ah non
non non et justement en réponse à votre
question précédente
nous allons utiliser aussi pour
communiquer ce que nous appelons les
fiches de la réussite tout ce qui a été
réussi par françois les fiches de laroui
à car il y en a 70
oui monsieur parce que nous même
quelquefois nous socialistes nous
arrivons à en oublier ce qui a été fait
par conséquent il faut le rappeler
eh bien je crois avoir comme unique déjà
là dessus mais il n'est jamais trop en
fait jamais trop
je continue est l'une de ces choses qui
ont été faits l'une de ces visites c'est
la dernière date qui va certainement je
respecte votre thèse est avec moi c'est
son passage de 7 à thébaux priori ça
devrait être huile
ça m'agace égalité réelle c'est une
avancée quand même considérable et
personne ne l'a fait avant nous mais je
veux aussi parler du de 10 emplois aidés
et j'en passe il y en a beaucoup ont
pour noms la campagne va commencer il y
aura des semaines pour pour en parler et
en débattre sur tout alors pour terminer
au frédéric bhérer premier secrétaire de
la fsl mais législatives vous êtes
toujours sur la même position en cette
fin d'année 2016 sur la même position de
candidat estampillé fsn pour les
premiers tours
et on verra ensuite pour les deuxième
tour comment vous allez mais où est ce
que cela a changé quoi sur ça vous ne me
ferez pas varié alors nous sommes nous
arrivons patiquement au terme de notre
calendrier nous avons les candidatures
qu'un déposait très bien les jeux vous
voir gagner je vais pas vous dévoiler
non non non non et nous le 14 par les
dieux du 15 vous saurez qui sont le
candidat du 15 janvier
oui merci frédéric bhérer